for dedicated TV fans getting attached
to your favorite characters is part of
the fun of watching but things can get
ugly when one of them gets killed off
whether they're objecting to the concept
of death in general or to a particular
brutal and undeserved end fans aren't
shy about letting everyone know how mad
they are when their fave kicks the
bucket house day here's a look back at
some of the character deaths that have
upset fans the most over the years and
here's your chance to click away if you
don't want to see any spoilers
Lexx up the 100 this post apocalyptic CW
drama spurred outrage when it killed off
LexA played by alycia debnam-carey not
only was LexA fan favorite but her
development arc had just reached an
important milestone
she and her romantic interest Clarke
played by Eliza Taylor had just slept
together for the first time fans were
angry about the interrupted storyline
but also incensed by the way lexis death
seemed to imply that the show saw its
gay characters as disposable the
backlash was so intense that showrunner
Jason Rothenberg ultimately apologized
to fans but there was no undoing the
source of their heartbreak sex and death
came so close together and I'm conscious
there was sort of optics of that being
uncomfortable
whosh Firefly Joss Whedon series about
outer space cowboys had legions of
dedicated fans we were left hanging when
the show was canceled after just one
season a problem Whedon tried to resolve
with the follow up feature film serenity
but while fans were thrilled to get some
closure
they weren't happy at all with this
moment in the movies third act when wash
played by Alan Tudyk
is killed by harpoon wielding Reavers
Emily Sano and watch out despite being
devastated most Firefly fans process
their grief and anger and eventually
found some peace but others couldn't let
go one man even claimed that washes
death defied the laws of physics
just like mouths beloved ship love keeps
your normal show follow Adriana The
Sopranos in a mobsters series that's
filled with gruesome murders none was
more tragic than the death of adriana la
cerva played by dre de Matteo adriana is
a good person who just wants to escape
into witness protection with her
boyfriend Christopher
but Christopher betrays her which she
realizes at the same time the audience
doesn't her heart-wrenching final scene
it was so brutal that some fans tried to
find hope in the fact that
driana was off-camera when Silvio pulled
the trigger could it be that like Tony
Soprano she's not really dead Joyce
summers Buffy the Vampire Slayer after
being ill for most of the fifth season
Buffy's mother Joyce is finally starting
to get better but then Buffy returns
home to find her mother motionless on
the couch dead from a sudden brain
aneurysm many fans were deeply upset
with showrunner Joss Whedon for killing
off Joyce
and they weren't the only ones even
Buffy herself Sarah Michelle Gellar
argued against the decision and I tried
so hard to talk about I was not happy
about it
although most fans now agree that the
body is one of the best episodes of the
entire series processing Joyce's death
definitely took some time and a lot of
tears lane Pryce Mad Men despite signs
throughout season 5 of Mad Men that Lane
was struggling with some heavy stuff his
suicide was still one of the most
upsetting moments in Sterling Cooper
history the ad man played by Jared
Harris had embezzled $1700 from the
agency to cover a debt a crime that Don
Draper discovers in despair Blaine
returns to the agency types of
resignation letter and hangs himself I
think something's terribly wrong with
mr. Pryce's office the distraught
reactions of lanes co-workers mirror
those of fans who were devastated to see
their favorite character meet such a
tragic untimely end Derek Shepherd
Grey's Anatomy
the doctor known as McDreamy was central
to this shondaland drama particularly
his rocky relationship with fellow doc
Meredith Grey but just when the couple
looked like they'd live happily ever
after a car accident leaves Derek brain
dead Meredith has to make the difficult
decision to remove him from life support
a plot twist that left many fans wanting
to pull the plug themselves under
televisions
[Music]
I am Colonel Blake mash and this
light-hearted comedy series the sudden
and unexpected death of Lieutenant
Colonel Blake in the third season was
unprecedented when actor McLean
Stevenson decided to leave the series
the show's creators wrote Blake off with
an honorable discharge only to cap the
episode with a devastating epilogue
Finlay Blake's plane was shot down over
the Sea of Japan the show received over
a thousand letters from viewers who
didn't appreciate this incredibly
depressing moment in a show that was
supposed to be funny
and they weren't alone the networks were
so upset about the scene CBS even cut it
entirely in later airings of the episode
Jax teller
Sons of Anarchy in the 2014 series
finale of Sons of Anarchy the antihero
played by Charlie Hunnam made a
controversial exit from the show and the
mortal plane by fleeing from the police
right into the path of an oncoming
18-wheeler Jax's suicide didn't sit well
with fans some thought he deserved
better and others thought he deserved
worse but above all everyone thought
that the computer-generated crows and
the final shots look completely
ridiculous
dan Connor Roseanne in the final season
of the long-running sitcom Roseanne
things take a turn for the weird the
Connor family wins the Illinois Lottery
Roseanne goes on Jerry Springer
dan has an affair and my writing is
really what got me through the last year
after Dan died I mean at first I felt so
betrayed as if he had left me for
another woman
wait what as it turns out dan is dead
killed by a heart attack at Darlene's
wedding and the crazy fantasies of
season 9 were just Roseanne's way of
coping with her grief many fans and
critics weren't too happy with the
bait-and-switch but in this case there's
good news John Goodman's dan will be
back from the dead in the Roseanne
revival which is reportedly going to
pretend the show's ninth season never
even happened the red wedding Game of
Thrones
well HBO's fantasy series is notorious
for killing off its characters this
multiple murders the one fans just can't
get over after reconciling with the
easily offended Lord Walder Frey Rob
stark and his retinue attend the
marriage of Edmure Tully to frays
daughter Roslyn and everything seems to
be going well until suddenly it isn't
[Music]
within just a few minutes Game of
Thrones killed off Robb Stark his wife -
Lissa his mother Catelyn and his
direwolf gray wind Twitter exploded with
angry profanity-laced tirades about the
killings with fans blaming Walder Frey
Roose Bolton and the Lannisters but also
the showrunners george RR martin and any
friends who had read the books and
didn't warn them ahead of time the moral
of this story
take it away Ramsay Bolton eating this
has happened
because it hasn't beaten paying
attention thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel let's check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]
[Applause]